All right, welcome back.
Twitter users voting for Elon Musk to step down as head of Twitter...
…less than two months after he took over the social media platform.
Yeah, this all happened last night.
Musk created a poll asking users if he should step down...
…saying he will abide by the results.
The poll closed this morning...
…and about fifty-seven percent of respondents said he should go.
More than seventeen million people have voted.
The poll followed another tweet where Musk said, quote,...
…"Going forward, there will be a vote for major policy changes."
"My apologies. Won't happen again."
Now, Musk's October takeover of the social media platform...
…has been marred in controversy amid the Tesla founder's mission...
...to make the platform a mainstay for free speech, but the restrictions keep coming.
On Sunday, the bird app announced it will ban accounts...
…that promote other social media sites.
We're talking Instagram, Facebook, Mastodon.
In a now deleted tweet, the tech company support account said,...
...it acknowledges that users are active on other social media sites,...
…but it will remove accounts specifically created...
...to promote sites or contain links and usernames pushing to other platforms.
However, social media sites like Tiktok and WhatsApp were not included in the ban.
Now, this is all happening as Elon Musk pushes for users to pay for the platform,...
…which has caused a lot of backlash to say the least.